i'm joined by michael clark our defense
analyst for a closer look at this so
michael just tell us where we are with
the fight for ukraine at the moment as
the russian forces have arrayed the
number of points around the country yes
i mean the russians began this with what
i would call a plan b which was uh to do
it the way western forces would have
done it with relatively light forces
moving quite quickly from the border to
surround key areas and moving quickly on
kiev get rid of the government declare
themselves a new government and that was
all supposed to be done within 72 hours
hasn't worked they've made a big mess of
it and the ukrainians have fought back
ferociously so now they've gone to plan
a which is what they know how to do
which is to move in more slowly with
heavier armor siege trains as they say
down the
nipple valley as you you've pointed out
there um in order to surround the big
cities and this has become a war of the
cities it's a north-south war at the
moment but it will
revolve around the cities the ukrainians
can't defend the whole country so they
defended the cities and the russians are
now moving in on all of those cities and
we're focusing on some of the cities in
more detail kirsten karkaven the latest
news we've got mario paul in a moment
but de nipro is interesting at the
moment isn't it as well because the the
defender there the ukrainian uh armed
forces
nepro uh is an area of about three
million people it's big industrial areas
about one million people in the city and
the uh leader of nipro uh uh mikola
lucasher um has said that he said i've
got a million people under arms the
russians are 90 miles away i will turn
this into a new stalingrad and i believe
him well that may well happen in the
coming days let's take a look close look
at the fight for the south of the
country focusing in on the cities of
kirsten odessa and mario paul now let's
uh talk about kirsan to start with now
we understand that this city is still
being contested by both russian and of
course ukrainian forces and also mario
pole in recent hours we've seen the
latest from the mayor there saying that
the city is coming under heavy
bombardment constant bombardment and
they are running out of water as the
russian forces continue to attack yes i
mean two key places here kirshan where
they're still fighting a major city
and that again should have fallen quite
quickly but it didn't um the russians
are clearly trying to create a land
corridor between the uh the uh
territories that they held in the
donbass through to crimea which was
annexed in 2014 mario paul right on the
edge of the disputed donbass area should
have fallen within hours we've been
saying that for days now and according
to the ukrainian government they are
still holding on in maripo i don't know
how they're doing it they're coming
under great pressure but there's some
sort of alamo going on there at some
point the russians almost certainly will
link up all of this southern area and
then they will start to push north up
the nepal valley to unite the north and
south of the country which they hope
that they will have taken
okay well uh
michael let's just take a quick look now
if we can at karakiv where we have seen
some more heavy fighting there has been
a russian elements that we understand
have
air lifted into the city of course still
being defended by the ukrainians there
was that attack on freedom square
yesterday as well so uh we are seeing
that this is under heavy uh
contestation by both sides yeah kaki the
second city very important city too and
the russians look as if they're now
adopting their plan a which is the way
they always do these things which is to
surround the city probably come and get
it from the east airborne drops we think
probably in the west um and where they
will sit outside the city bombard the
strategic centers as they see them they
won't worry too much about civilian
casualties and then they probably would
would uh start to bombard civilian areas
in order to break the spirit of the
civilians and then just move in and what
happens in kharkiv in the next two or
three days
almost certainly will be what will
happen in kiev
probably sometime next week okay michael
clark for now thank you very much